[Music]
fifteen help guests are about to be
locked away and the Big Brother house
received in nineteen and Kevin grazier
got a private tour inside from host
Julie Chen
welcome to the new season 19 Big Brother
house Wow
total redo this year's theme is all
about temptation forbidden fruit there's
always at least one two possibly three
bad apples in the bunch check out all
these tempting Big Brother bucks
except this money is fake Hollywood
money made to look real as you can see
motion picture use only and the house is
appropriately equipped with the greed
room over-the-top decadence if it makes
me think of Michael Douglas it whilst
Wall Street greed for lack of a better
word is good but what if you lose a
challenge welcome to the have-nots room
locked for now for a week they have no
hot water in the shower
uncomfortable bed and the lights don't
go out so it's like man on the flip side
we have the show man's room flowers you
know every bed is a double bed they step
till all hours of the night doing lord
knows what and every bit of the action
4,700 square foot pressure cooker will
be caught by big brothers 100
microphones and 87 cameras even in the
bathroom we cannot have any space that a
secret conversation can take place of
course the head of household suite is
back and this time decadently redecorate
it it's gold and it's greedy in here
there's even an aquarium and a
chandelier in the bathroom whoa whoa
as for Kevin if he rang it in the house
while he admits you'd find him in the
sloth room oh my gosh if you had this in
a TV Oh unbelievable Oh
I'll see you later I'm good I'm good I
think Kevin's moving in far from a
slothful confidently in motion
well last year's winner Nicole Franzel
spent a record 99 date under the
microscope this year's winner getting
off easy trap for only 92 days
you